At this point I'm going to
skip over a bunch of details.
For example which features are we
going to use to make their code words?
What size should there be when
you do a vector quantization?
Sometimes it'll tell you how many
code words it thinks it needs or
sometimes you give it a number.
We're not going to talk about that,
and we're not even going to talk about
the clustering or
the vector quantization algorithm.
Instead we're going to focus on how
would you use that in a way that relates
to the SVMs that we just talked
about in order to do recognition.
So, what we do is we're going to
continue with our analogy to documents.
So here I have two different documents.
And if you take a look at the document
on the left you'll see a whole bunch of
words in here.
Right, sensory, brain, visual,
perception, et cetera, nerve,
image Hubel, Wiesel.
Hubel and Wiesel, by the way,
are people who won Nobel Prize for
understanding what goes on in the visual
cortex of the cat, all right?
And here's another document.
China, trade, surplus exports, domestic,
foreign, increase, trade, value.
Notice that what's in the magnifying
glasses are not ordered.
It's just the words that
happened to be in that document.
It's like you stuck all
the words in a bag.
And that's where we get this
notion of bag of words.
Okay, and the goal of what we're
going to talk about now is to go from
object recognition and
map that onto a bag of words.
And in the document world, you know, one
way of doing this is I have my bag of
words and I say, what is the
distribution of words in this document?
And if I wanted to do
document retrieval,
I want to find other similar documents,
a simple thing you might do is find
other documents that have sort of the
same histogram distribution of words.
And that,
that's likely to be a matching document.
Things are much more sophisticated
now in terms of how that works.
But it's, the basic idea is that I've
got these code words that represent or
these words that represent
something about the semantics.
And so a similarity in
distribution tells me that,
maybe there's a good chance that
it's a similar type of document.
So we want to do this
in computer vision.
So that's notionally represented here.
So I've got a bunch of
different objects and
I compute my features over all
of these different objects.
And I come up with what's
shown down here, and
I think this side is
originally from [FOREIGN].
I'm not sure.
And all of these,
these are all of my code words for
all of my different objects, right?
So I take all my objects, and
it's kind of like if you take
all the documents in a,
a library in United States,
and if they're all in English, you
took all of those documents together.
All of the words would be
the set of the words that span
all of those documents, right?
And in fact there are many more
documents than there are words.
And in fact if you think of important
words, words that actually have a lot of
meaning, there's way more
documents than words.
So given a collection of words,
visual words,
for every document, I can say how many
of each word is in each document.
And that's what these histograms
are meant to represent, right?
So you know, the bicycle has got
these little bicycle pieces in it.
All right, and something that
might kind of look like this.
I don't know, maybe, you know,
this brown part down here looks a little
bit like that brown part down there.
But the idea is that there's many more
of the bicycle elements than there
are of the, the violin elements.
This is referred to as a bag of
visual words, for obvious reasons.
And the idea is that you're
describing the entire image
just by the histogram or
the collection of those words.
And the, and you want to do access
the same way that you did in
the documents world.